this episode of the minimalist podcast
is brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means
to live a meaningful life with less ryan
nicodemus is on vacation so today's
episode
i'm going to sneak into his apartment
and get rid of everything
just kidding today i do want to tackle
one of the most frequent minimalism
conundrums
that people have man this seems to be a
problem for so many people
and if you're watching this on youtube
you can actually see that i'm surrounded
by book clutter book
clutter is today's topic we're going to
talk about books we'll probably talk a
little bit
about writing as well but i enjoy
reading books
i want to talk about why i enjoy reading
books i want to talk about what kind of
books i enjoy how i read them it's not
just
physical print books like all of these
books around me i have this device in my
pocket where i can listen to books
i have this device here where i can read
there's a thousand
plus books on this device if you're
watching this it's a kindle
other e-readers work really well also
we got this tweet from adam on twitter
he said he talked about this term
uh sundooku i'm sure some of you have
heard of it
it's a japanese term it means acquiring
reading materials
but letting them pile up in one's home
without reading them
now does that sound like you have you
ever purchased a book
and just not read it it was an
aspirational purchase
i know i have in fact i used to have
about 2 000 books there's an
essay in one of our books called
essential i'll hold this up for the
camera here it's an essay collection
ryan and i wrote 150 different essays
about intentional living
12 different areas of intentional living
one of those areas is stuff
and one part of our stuff at least for
most of us
has to do with our books or our book
collection now i used to own
2 000 books and this essay is called i
got rid of
2 000 books i'll just read this really
quickly as a way to kick off this
episode then we'll get into your
questions
i used to own 2 000 books slightly more
than that actually i had all kinds of
books
hardcovers paperbacks trade paperbacks
literary fiction writing and grammar
books books of photography
self-help books my dec my deceased
father's collection of old medical
journals
genre fiction those cute little pop-up
books
you name it i had shelves and shelves
and more
shelves of books some of which i
actually read
and many of which i'd read someday
you know whenever i got around to it
but who was i kidding i thought my
overflowing shelves of books
made me look important intelligent and
cool
look at me i know how to read a lot
what's worse i thought these books made
me somebody
they were part of my identity these
books
were a part of me and once
something's a part of your identity once
it becomes part of you
it's exceedingly hard to shed this is
true for anything we incorporate into
our identities our careers our cars our
homes
our possessions our sentimental items
these things become part of us and they
become anchors in our lives
anchors that keep us at bay away from
the freedom
of the open seas and then i go into
how i let go of 2 000 books but that's
really what we're going to talk about
today
i think that was my main problem i still
get immense value from books
the point of that essay is that i
actually got rid of 2
000 books but started reading more
as a result no longer will my book
purchases
aspirational but well why do we read
books right
we want to read more we don't want to
own more books i think that should
really be
the point of all of this unfortunately
we have
conflated the two we confuse
owning a book with the value of the book
the value is not in this artifact
if you buy a copy of this book essential
that i'm holding up here or any of these
other books i have on the table
there's no value in fact it's just a
paperweight an ironic paperweight that's
made of paper
and you're not going to get value from
it unless you actually do
something with it which is really a
metaphor for life
right and so what i hope to talk about
today
is not to say get rid of your books if
you find immense value in your book
collection
i encourage you to not get rid of it but
i know a lot of you struggle
and say how can i let go of all of these
books that i've purchased
and so we're going to talk today about
that we're going to talk about how i
read books now you see
i have a lot of print books around me i
i do
read books on my kindle quite frequently
as well
because that app also works well on my
phone so if i'm standing in line at
chipotle or well remember we could go
out and stand in line in places when
that was a thing
by the way i'm here with jordan no more
on podcast sean
they'll be joining me on the microphone
occasionally and especially during the
maximal episode
the minimalists.com support if you want
to listen to that
we're going to do a deep dive into some
of our favorite books my favorite books
different types of writing different
types of books
and we're going to read from some books
as well a bit of a different
type of maximal episode but today for
the minimal episode
i want to go ahead and get into your
questions our first question today is
from
danielle in missoula montana so i have a
ton of books
that i have had the intention of reading
there's a lot of books i still haven't
read
and so i don't know pardon me just like
i don't know if i should get rid of them
or if i should keep them with an instead
of goal
to read them by a certain time if i
haven't read them
by a certain time then get rid of them
just wanted to get
your input as to how to move forward
well i think there's a couple good
options there you just laid them out
pretty simply here it's your intention
to read them right i think that's why we
bring books in
we usually intend to read them i've
never bought a book that i didn't intend
to read
although i've bought a lot of books that
i never
read before and so i think we need to
set some rules up here now you've
already established that you can do
that right you've said well should i
keep them with a goal that i'm going to
read them
and if that makes sense and you feel
that you can fulfill that
objective then yeah sure why not or or
should i get rid of them
and i think the answer is it really
depends on on your temperament if these
books are
weighing you down if they're getting in
the way if there's a lot of
psychological weight
if they're taking up too much space in
your home and
and that is causing some emotional
weight then i would say by all means
clean slate get rid of them but
if you have some books and you know that
you have an opportunity to read them
they're
they're not just in case items they're
just for when you're able to pick them
up
then yeah i think it's important to set
up a rule to have a a bit of a deadline
and it doesn't have to be the 90 90 rule
which is something we talk about in our
minimalist rule book which
uh we'll give you a copy for free
danielle it's free for everyone actually
the minimalists.com
rulebook or if you want the audiobook
version we just did an audiobook version
for that
you can listen to that and it's it's a
different kind of audio book
we recorded like 16 different mini
podcasts with that
to go along with each of those 16 rules
for living with less but one of those
rules is
the 90-90 rule have i used this in the
last 90 days will i use it in the next
90 days now
a lot of these books let me pick up one
here this is a book called anything you
want
by derek sivers what a phenomenal book
this
is and actually this is one of the
there's maybe three books that i
buy by the case i purchase by the case
and i hand them out to people friends
family etc anyone who i think would find
value from it
and this one in particular i think it's
88 pages of of zen
wisdom about business and well
it says it's for entrepreneurs but
anyway this book i can look at it and
say
have i used this in the last 90 days
will i use it in the next 90 days if not
i give myself permission to let go now
maybe 90 days is not the appropriate
timeline
for you with a lot of these books that
you have danielle
of course you haven't used in the last
90 days but maybe it's a one year rule
for you maybe it's
hey am i going to read this in the next
year
now if you want to get strict and maybe
it's 90 days maybe it's 30 days you give
yourself the opportunity to really
whittle down that collection of books
you're actually going to read within the
next year
and be honest with yourself how many
books are you reading a month
the average person is less than one
which by the way the only
numeral less than one is zero and so
the average person reads next to nothing
and so if you can commit to just reading
one book a year then keep 12 books that
you have
you don't even need to add any more to
the collection and
you can get rid of everything else and
by the way you can always bring
something back in
if you absolutely find that wow i miss
this for some reason
now i'll talk to you about some of the
books that i hold on to for longer than
that that fall outside of a
a 90 90 rule and it's a lot of reference
books or just some of my favorite books
today today on the maximal we're
actually going to go over my my 17
or maybe it's 14 favorite books i
haven't decided which yet
also six books i wish i would have
i would have written and those books i
go back to all the time one of those
books
is right here this is david foster
wallace's first essay collection it's
called a supposedly fun thing i'll never
do again holding this up for the cameras
on
youtube and i think it's a masterpiece
of a book
essays and arguments especially the
experiential essays that
take place throughout this book the
title essay there's another one called a
ticket to the fair
it's actually uh that's the the shorter
version that's the harper's version
but there is a an essay here about the
county fair in illinois which is
hilarious and informative and
and you know there's something about a
collection like that that i keep
going back to i may not read it cover to
cover but i go back to it very regularly
and
my wife hasn't read a whole lot of david
foster wallace so from time to time
when we're doing our morning reading
i'll just pop out one of his books
and dive into an essay read a paragraph
or a page or two
and have that shared experience together
there are other books like reference
books that i use
all the time i mean this book right here
which i'll hold up
is like a door stop getting a workout
just lifting it this is gardner's modern
american usage
it's a usage dictionary now it's a
not a dictionary in the traditional
sense like you don't look up words
necessarily
but you look up parts of speech
and it directs you how to better write
how to better use those parts of speech
so as a writer i'll
often look something up let me give you
an example i'll just flip to a page
really quickly and here it talks about
compose versus comprise
and what's the difference between we
often use that word comprised
incorrectly right i'll say you know
sean's outfit was comprised of a shirt
shoes and pants that's the incorrect way
to use the word
you would say it's composed right the
and so um a usage dictionary shows you
how to
correctly use standard american english
and so that's something i go back to
regularly there are other books that i
use as
inspiration for when i'm writing and
we're going to go through some of those
on
the maximal episode but daniel i'm going
to move on to another question i hope
you enjoy that copy of
the minimalist rule book either the
audiobook
or the free e-book over at the
minimalists.com
rulebook nicole in lincoln nebraska has
a question for us
my biggest question is books i love
books so much
i really don't have a lot of books but
the books that i do have
i really love are in our garage because
our apartment is too small to
have a bookcase and share all the books
with everybody but i really do love them
um i'm just knowing that my husband is
going to want me to get rid of them
so that is my question is what should we
do with those
so nicole yeah yes this is
a problem for for several reasons i'll
talk to you about how i i
use well how i store my own books how
i've tackled this problem in my own life
but shawn podcast john do you have any
advice for nicole
yeah i said uh get rid of the husband
and keep the books
well hopefully he's not going to give
you that that ultimatum right
uh and you said he wants you to get rid
of the books and i think the reason
being it's not that he doesn't want you
to have
joy from your books it's they're taking
up a lot of space
in your shared space and so what my wife
and i have done together is we have two
small bookshelves if you go to our home
tour which you can find on the resources
page
of theminimalists.com the
minimalists.com
resources you can see a home tour me and
my wife have two
bookshelves there and
once those bookshelves are filled up we
could very easily buy more bookshelves
or i guess we could we don't have a
garage but we have a we
our building has a a small garage in and
we have this tiny little storage space
in that garage area that could fit some
books i could cram it full of books
but why would i do that now i want to
talk to you nicole about
the way you're talking about your books
and i think if you're trying to let go
of the attachment with these books
you said you love them so much
and that indicates to me that i haven't
done a very good job
of teaching you to love people and use
things there's nothing wrong with
enjoying the experience of books in fact
i really encourage you to do that i
think books can do some things that
other mediums like film or even music
can't do
and so i'm a big fan of books and i
think that's what you mean
i really do think that's what you mean i
don't think you mean you love them i
think we have a language problem
right because you could say i love tacos
but i also
love my husband wow
what does that mean does it mean the
same thing that it's a difficult
decision but choosing between the two
no well hopefully you don't have to
choose between tacos and your husband or
books
and your husband but you do need to form
some sort of daytaunt in your household
and that means setting up some limits
because otherwise we don't have limits
we can let
everything in if everything is precious
to us
then nothing is precious to us
you could tweet that podcast sean now i
would love for you to start changing
your language around books
i don't want you to be less excited i
want you to pick up this book
the answers by katherine lacy which i
could tell you i think a few years ago i
would have said i
love this book because it's such a great
experience i dive into the consciousness
of the author of the characters
it's an amazing book but what i really
mean is
man i enjoy this book and there are
times where
there's nothing i would rather do than
explore the pages the world
within this book there was a writer i
think it was rick moody i heard him talk
about
why he chose to be a writer someone in
an interview asked him
hey you know there's all these other
things you can do you could be a yoga
instructor
you could be an astronaut you could be
a hunter you could be a school teacher
you could be an accountant you could be
a detective
you could be a trash collector
why are you a writer why didn't you
decide to be one of these things and he
thought about it for a moment paused
and said i guess i decided to be a
writer
because it's the only profession
in which i could be all of those things
i can be the trash collector and the
yoga instructor
and the detective i could be anything i
want if i'm a writer and i think the
same is true
when we really get lost in the book as a
reader i can
take on the life of those characters a
great writer
is not making the story with the reader
they're the dictator of their own world
they've created this world for you
and it's a beautiful world it's a sad
world
it's an elated world it's an exciting
world it's a terrifying world
depending on how the author sets that up
and i want to get lost in books it
sounds like you do too
but right now you're lost in them
physically they're stacked all around
you
but you maybe you're not getting the
value from them you actually could
of course i'm not telling you to get rid
of all of your books but maybe there's
some sort of limitation that you and
your husband can agree on
for me that's two bookshelves that hold
about 40 books each
so i guess that means we probably have
about 80 books at home but anytime
one of us brings home a new book from
our local bookstore
or if we order one online we have to get
rid of
a book that's on there because i don't
have any more room and it'd be silly
for me to just keep adding to the piles
more and more and more
it allows me to think about a book
before i bring it into my life but also
i don't treat any of them as precious
i'm willing to let any of them
go and especially if it's a book i get a
lot of joy from
those are the books i let go most
fervently
because i want other people to get joy
from those as well
so if after this jordan were to come up
to me and he would have said hey man i
really you know i've been thinking about
writing a memoir and
i see you've got this book by mary carr
it's called the art of memoir
can i read that i said yeah have it i
want you to get value from it
i care about jordan and i know that one
of the ways to add value to his life
is to contribute to him in some way and
if i think this would add value to his
life and it's not
giving a gift but in a way it is gift
giving
it's it's a way to add value to someone
else's life so be willing
to let go of these especially if they're
no longer adding value to you
because if they're no longer adding
value to you then one of the
kindest most compassionate things you
can do for the people around you
is let go of them so someone else can
get value
from those books speaking of books
nicole i'm going to send you a copy
of one of our books that might sound uh
cruel at this point that i'm sending you
a book and you're dealing with a
collection of books so
maybe instead of the print book which i
have here it's my favorite book that
we've ever written it's called
everything that remains
it's a five-year journey of me and ryan
being the suit and tie corporate guys to
becoming
the minimalists and one of my favorite
openings of anything that we've written
i'll read a little bit from
the the opening of everything that
remains
this is the first chapter called
fluorescent ghosts
our identities are shaped by the
costumes we wear
i'm seated in a cramped conference room
surrounded by ghosts and shirt sleeves
and pleated trousers
there are 35 maybe 40 people here middle
managers the lot of us
mostly caucasian mostly male all
oozing apathy the group's median
complexion is that of an agoraphobe
a microsoft excel spreadsheet is
projected onto an oversized canvas
pulled from the ceiling
at the front of the room the canvas is
flimsy and cracked and is a shade of
off-white that suggests it's a relic
from a time when employees were allowed
to smoke indoors
the rest of the room is aggressively
white
the walls are white the ceiling is white
the people are white as if all cut from
the same materials
well everyone except stan seated at the
back of the room
i'll pause it there but i hope you
enjoyed this copy of everything that
remains if you like our podcast i think
you really enjoy the audiobook version
and that won't add to your book
clutter or if you want the ebook version
we're happy to send that to you
as well nicole enjoy everything that
remains
we have another question here from
julian in victoria bc canada
i'm moving pretty soon here and i have a
bunch of books that's where my
grandmother's
which i'm having a really hard time
letting go of and i'm wondering if
there's any
way you could suggest to minimalize them
i was thinking maybe some form of
digital
copy or i'd still like to read them
eventually at least some of them but
some of them just hold a bit of
sentimental value
so here's any uh suggestions you guys
have for that that would be great
julian i've had to go through this a
couple times in in my own life
so my father died when i was a young kid
and he left some books behind um
and we had them all throughout my
childhood they were in this
big dresser book cabinet thing that he
had
and they became a fixture of my
childhood so
i certainly resonate with the
sentimental item aspect of that and then
of course
when my mother died when i was 29 years
old
28 years old somewhere around there
yeah i was 28 and
she left me a bunch of books well she
didn't leave them to me they were just
left behind right
and i was in a very similar situation to
you because
i knew i wanted to read some of these
books or at least thought i did and so
i held on to the ones i was sure i
wanted to read
and i took photos of all the other ones
so i knew that if i ever wanted to
replace them in the future
i'd have access to those books if i
needed to buy them
again for some reason if my mom really
liked
a you know dave edgar's novel i could
pick it back
up in the future there's no shortage of
books
and so i look at i looked at my mom's
books and then
i got back home and i realized i was
still holding on to all of my father's
books from my childhood as well
and i hadn't read a single one of them
and
i was honest with myself i looked myself
in the mirror and i said
i'm not planning i have no plans of
reading any of
these books and
i need to give myself permission to let
go of at least some of them
i need to get some momentum here because
i had none at that point and so
it started with just getting rid of one
book seeing how easy that was
saying that i wasn't harmed by it in
fact letting go is
freeing it's also free by the way it
doesn't cost you anything
to let go but it does free up some space
in your
life and so i'm not telling you to get
rid of all of your grandmother's books
i'm really sorry that you have to deal
with this
and i think there's a lesson here for
parents and grandparents
with leaving our stuff to to other
people
let's not leave behind things that
people aren't going to get value from
right and how do we determine that well
it means having some conversations while
we're still here
on this earth and when i'm
looking at julian your situation
i get it there's some sentimental value
in these items but
items have sentimental item value
because we
give them sentiment we've assigned
meaning
to them but this book let me pull up a
book here what do i have here
oh rupee core the sun and her flowers my
favorite book of poetry she's an amazing
poet
this book doesn't have inherent meaning
now of course it means something
different to rupee who wrote it than it
does to me the reader who really enjoys
this book and i
read from this all the time it
definitely would fit in my 90-90 rule
probably my 30-30 rule i
will just pick up a page and i will
read it to my wife or i'll send her a
picture of a particular poem
that is resonating with me right then
and i'm not even a huge poetry fan but i
get a lot of value from it
and that's what i want for the books
that you have is i want books you're
going to return to books you're going to
get value from and if
that value is in any of those books i
would encourage you to read those but
maybe set up some rules like we talked
about with danielle earlier
on am i going to read this in the next
year be honest with yourself
and maybe even hold on to it for the
next year if you feel like you're going
to but then if you don't
give yourself permission to let it go if
you feel like it's getting in the way
now of course there are many of you
reading this or listening to this rather
who are listening right now and saying
well i've got a whole
giant room full of books bookshelves
full of books
and they're not bothering me at all in
fact i get great joy
from being able to go in that room pick
up the books and smell them
and the tactile feel great
if it's not bothering you then why
deprive yourself right now i might say
it might make sense to temporarily
deprive yourself to box them all up for
a month and see if
you actually get more value without them
not get rid of them necessarily
these stoical experiments help us
determine what we really get value from
as opposed to
the perceived value just because it's
always been there
and so you can do your own version of a
sort of packing party with books
and to see whether or not you get value
from them and if so
then bring them back in but if you
realized it was faux value if this was
an imaginary value
then it might be time to reassess and to
let go of
those books that are actually in the way
julian i'm gonna send you a copy of a
book it's called essential and
in that book it's there's that essay
where i talk about the
2000 books that i got rid of and
actually started reading more in the
process
but there's also a essay in there about
how i deal with sentimental
items and i think that one will help you
out the most
and it's called letting go of
sentimental items i think you'll enjoy
that so
if you want the audiobook version if you
like our podcast i think you'll
certainly enjoy the audiobook version
of essential it's over six hours long
it's our longest audio book
or if you want the book book or the
ebook i'm happy to send those to you as
well julian
enjoy all right it's time for our
lightning round this is where we answer
your text messages text your questions
and comments to
937-202-4654
and this week if you text an emoji of a
book
just text us an emoji of a book we'll
add you to our monday morning
minimal maxims list that way we'll start
your week out with a little bit of
simplicity a monday morning minimal
maxim each week week just a
a short burst of
letting go at the beginning of each week
something to inspire you
to let go all right we got a question
here from bethany how do i
let go of my emotional attachment to
each book i own
they all make me feel something so it's
hard to get rid of them
isn't that fascinating so making you
feel something maybe shouldn't be the
criteria
for holding on to something right they
all might make you feel something
but they make you feel something good
all my stuff you know the average
american household has 300 000 items in
it when i before i became a minimalist i
was a well organized hoarder i probably
had more than
300 000 items and all that stuff made me
feel something
but most of it made me feel miserable it
made me feel
anxious made me feel overwhelmed made me
feel discontented
so they might make you feel something
but i think maybe what you mean bethany
is
they make you feel good but i think
that's not even criteria
to hold on to something either don't
confuse pleasure
with joy with meaning
with contentment or even with happiness
they might make you feel something but
you might feel
better after you let go there's
something pithy in there you could tweet
sean i do have a pity answer for you
here
we call these minimal maxims we try to
answer your your lightning round and 140
characters less we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes so you can copy and share or pick
the answers on social media if you like
by the way you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place for free
minimal maxims.com minimal maxim this
week is
clinging is always an inappropriate way
to hold on
clinging is always an inappropriate way
to hold on so
i think what happens when we get
overwhelmed we don't even know where to
start so we don't let go
or we don't let go what do we do we
start clinging
because something is no longer adding
value to us we we're just holding on to
it so tightly
we can't possibly let go and so of
course the first
step in letting go is not just dropping
the thing it's loosening your grip
there are a bunch of ways you can do
that we talk about it in the minimalist
rule book
and we obviously talk about it and
everything that remains but
when i think about letting go
i think about what what's what are the
benefits of letting go it's not just
getting rid of the stuff
because if you just get rid of the books
you go home today get rid of all your
books
a month from now a quarter from now a
year from now you're probably just going
to have another book problem right
it's understanding the benefits of
letting go
that's important the why behind the what
if you understand why
these things are stressing you out and
why you want to let go what are the
benefits maybe it means you have more
space maybe it means less cleaning maybe
it means you're going to start reading
more because you're able to focus on the
few books that you actually
own maybe it means you'll get more joy
from those reference books that you do
keep around
those 20 to 40 to 80 books that you
you keep around you know i think it was
marie kondo jordan who who said uh
30 books is the perfect amount of books
to own so do you own the perfect amount
of books
yes we have a and i had to throw away
the three minimalist books to make it ah
ah throw them away um just kidding
i'm just kidding he burned them uh so so
no
that's what's fascinating about this is
i can appreciate
the the marie kondo thought process of
minimizing
the books but i think that's an
inappropriate number for most
people for me 30 books would probably be
okay
now i probably have 40 books and my wife
has 40 books and so we have 80 total
so if you combine those do i have 10 too
many books
well maybe but or maybe i have too few
books
as well maybe what is too
much for me is not enough for you or
vice versa
i don't think there's a perfect number
of books for you to own
in fact there was a period of time in my
early 30s where i owned
zero physical books i did that
intentionally
and so i've brought book physical print
books back into my life because
sometimes i find that it's
more appropriate to have a print book
sean let me ask you a podcast sean you
you
enjoy a kindle you enjoy audiobooks as
well
but there's also something about print
books so how do you make the distinction
how do you decide
what you want out of a book and what
format is the best format
that's a really good question usually
reference books i keep hardback copies
of those
i'm going back to those all the time so
i usually keep a physical copy of those
um with fiction
i was doing the kindle quite a bit um
and that was more convenience thing
right you can keep everything right
there you can take it on the plane
you can pop it out uh use the kindle app
on your phone like
when you're waiting in line at the bank
or at a restaurant
because everything's carryout now um
but uh i found myself and i think you
and i've talked about this
going back to physical books more and
more
um for fiction too because of the
interaction i can have with it
yeah um i find myself underlining lines
i really like i
like sure that physical interaction or
uh marginalia
you know writing the margins asking
questions
uh writing notes to myself and i feel at
that point i'm really uh
interacting with the author i'm having a
conversation with the author
yeah and that's one of the things that
the books do really well is
even if the author isn't alive david
foster wallace is a prime example of
this he's not here but you can still
have an exchange of consciousness
and by the way you can have exchange of
consciousness with someone
with whom you were born after they died
and you do that through this medium
called
a book or through writing or the page
right
you you mentioned the highlighting lines
here this is
um oh man so this book i mentioned it a
moment ago the answers by katherine lacy
and we'll wrap up the lightning round
here but i'll just find there there's
several things that are underlined here
and this is well here let's just um
oh this is about love this is so good i
knew that this sort of love
technically was just a neurotransmitter
cocktail designed to make you feel
invincible
and infinite beyond language
beyond logic but i also knew that love
was as thrilling as it was
temporary a prelude to pain
though i only know knew this through
reading
which is to say i had not really learned
it yet and may never
that little shimmer in the chest how
simple it seems
it only seems that way she talks about
love quite a bit
and some of these opening chapters of
the book and there's a few things
underlined here but i will say you can
actually do that really well with a
kindle
also and i i've noticed this when i
read a book on a kindle especially
strangely the iphone app works even
better than the kindle
in many respects where i can highlight i
can change the highlight colors
i can make notes in the book and so you
can sort of do the marginalia thing now
with a kindle it's not the same tactile
experience
and i find that a lot of books there are
certain books that a tactile experience
is is better i the gardener's book for
example the
the modern american usage dictionary
yeah that one makes a lot more sense as
a physical book
there are other books however we're
going to talk on the maximum episode
about some david foster wallace's works
like infinite jest
it has the end notes oh you could even
say
everything that remains has end notes as
well everything that remains is arguably
better on a kindle
because you're able to go back and forth
between the endnotes which ryan is inter
literally interrupting me throughout the
book
and we we set it up intentionally that
it's supposed to be an interruption
throughout the book so
i think there's 208 interruptions
throughout this book something like that
and so you're reading a page you're on
page
81 say and then all of a sudden you see
there's there's one interruption on this
page you have to
go to the back of the book but it's
supposed to be that way it's supposed to
be memetic
of ryan's in my relationship as you know
if you're a longtime listener of this
podcast
we interrupt each other a lot and that's
what we do
with everything that remains but you can
do that on a kindle and maybe the
transitions are a little bit smoother
or if you're driving all the time you
probably shouldn't be reading
any text the audiobook is a better
format for that i also go on long walks
quite frequently
audio books are much better on my walks
the nice thing about a kindle is i can
switch between the audible app
and the kindle and it will pick up where
i left off listening
to go back into the book where i am
reading
and so i think there's room for all
three
formats you may prefer one over the
other but i think sometimes it depends
on what book you're going to read i
think the best format
is the format you're going to use most
frequently so
if you're going to read more on a kindle
don't think of kindle is going to make
you read more by the way it's not
the print book isn't going to make you
read more the audiobook isn't going to
make you
consume more books you just need to
figure out what is the best
vehicle for you in order to
move forward last thing i'll say for
bethany here
she says uh they all make me feel
something it's so hard to get rid of
them
well i talked about how meaning is often
manufactured right
well then if that's the case then you
might need to replace some of those
books you're no longer
reading that you want to let go of
clearly you want to let go of them
because you're asking this question
again this isn't for someone who doesn't
want to let go of their books
if you want to keep your books keep your
books but if you're struggling with
holding on to them and you wish you had
fewer books
then maybe replacing them with something
that is more meaningful
and i mean a physical thing i mean an
experience experiences
are inherently meaningful
whereas physical things have only the
meaning we
assign to them all right well we've got
some listener tips today and
also an added values segment i'm going
to recommend a book that is being turned
into a movie
before we get into that we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week like
i started listening to audiobooks how
can i let go of the physical books on my
shelves
do you keep books with personalized
signatures
i think my answer on this one is going
to surprise you
also what can books do for us that can't
be accomplished with any other
medium we're going to dive deep into
that plus we have questions about
book clutter versus book collections
what's the difference there
what do you do with marked up books
ebooks versus print books we're going to
talk about the six books
i wish i would have written we're going
to talk about my 14 favorite books
we're going to talk about the 50 best
book stores in the united states or at
least we'll
highlight a few i've got an article to
read from with the 50 best books
book stores in the united states
and a million more questions about books
also we're going to talk a little bit
about writing
on this week's maximal episode
it's over on the minimalist private
podcast it's a completely separate
podcast
this is where ryan and i we in our
guests
we we let our hair down we dive into
more sensitive subjects more long-form
subjects
by the way if you're not a private
podcast subscriber you're literally
missing two-thirds of our show
so i know you're spending money on
coffee every week and if you get value
from that
great but what we try to do is deliver
way more than two dollars worth of value
which is how much our private podcast
costs and it keeps this podcast 100
advertisement free so we're not talking
about supplements we're not talking
about mattresses or bed sheets we're not
bombarding you
with these advertising messages i think
those messages are insidious and if you
want to help us stay
advertisement-free this is the best way
to do that but
it doesn't just help us stay
advertisement-free you get something out
of the exchange here
you get to dive deep with us on a
private podcast
the reason we do this is because we want
to
we want to add value to your lives in a
different way there are some things that
are
much more difficult to discuss in public
in these private conversations
with our smaller private podcast
audience
or are the way for us to have these
conversations in a way where
really people let us mess up in public
and so thank you if you are a patreon
supporter if you want to support us
the minimalists.com support to subscribe
you'll also get a personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app all right here are some voicemail
comments from our listeners check them
out hey there
this is jesse from germany and i want to
share a tip for decorations
there's art libraries in many places
which allow you to take home pieces of
art for a couple of weeks
and that's great for either having cool
pieces of art at home that cost almost
nothing or it's a good way to figure out
what kind of art fits your style before
actually purchasing anything
my name is kb i'm from melbourne i just
had a tip for
everyone out there who also had
collected magazines
and been hoarding them for a few years
such as myself
high schools really appreciate the
donation if you know a teacher
or there's a local school nearby uh just
ask the art teacher or the fashion
teacher if they need some new magazines
for collaging
when i was in high school this was
always one of my favorite activities
and they're not that easy to come by if
you don't want to buy them
so just get them out of your life unless
you still read them but
chances are you probably don't all right
y'all thanks again to me for joining you
today
let me know if you like these solo
episodes i'm happy to do more of them if
you're finding
value in it we could even do more over
on patreon by the way
if you're not a private podcast
supporter like i said check it out just
give it a chance
give it a chance for a month i guarantee
you we have a whole back archive
hundreds of old
episodes uh not old but the their
previous episodes where
you'll find immense value in a lot of
these episodes hundreds of hours
of material out there for you to dive
into private podcast material you can't
find anywhere else except on our private
podcast
speaking of value for our added value
segment this week
there's a book that i really really
enjoy they're turning into a film by the
time
this comes out it will be out as a film
on netflix the book
is called the devil all the time by
donald ray pollock
i've met donald once we had lunch in
ohio he's from chillicothe ohio
actually he's from a small little town
outside of there that is now a ghost
town
called nakam stiff ohio and the devil
all the time
takes place in nakam stiff ohio
phenomenal book i mean his story is
amazing in fact
hopefully we'll have some time to dive
into it but real quick
at around age 50 he decided he wanted to
quit his factory job he worked at a
local
local paper mill and decided to walk
away from that become a full-time
fiction writer and made it work
he hadn't written fiction before then i
mean he had dabbled obviously and he
read a lot though
it's a great success story because it
shows that you're it's never too late
you're never too old
by the time he was 55 he had two books
published and i believe he has four
books published now
but the devil all the time is now being
made into this beautiful hollywood film
on netflix the trailer looks amazing by
the time this episode comes out
next week it will also be available for
you to watch on netflix but
this is one of those things where i'm
going to be the book snob and say you've
got to read the book it's such a good
book but
at the very least i guess you can check
out the film it's called the devil
all the time by donald ray pollock we'll
put a link to that
in the show notes real quick for right
here right now
here's one thing or maybe two or three
things going on in the life of
the minimalists speaking of reading if
you've
decided you wanted to start writing i
have a free ebook for you it's called
11 ways to write better you can find
that over at my website called
howtowritebetter.org that's where i
teach my writing class a couple times a
year
and a lot of things i teach my students
you get a high level version of it in
that free ebook
you just put in your email address i'll
also keep you posted on whenever that
writing class opens back up
howtowritebetter.org
to get your free ebook of 11 ways
to write better also speaking of books
ryan and i have written three books
everything that remains essential and
our first book minimalism
live a meaningful life not only are they
available as
books and ebooks and audiobooks
but they're available in over a dozen
different languages now so i know we
have a lot of uh
only about 50 of our audience sean is in
the us
the other 50 are all over the world
right there's 193 countries out there
and they're available in over a dozen
languages you can find out which
countries they're available and if you
go to the minimalists.com
foreign you can see which countries
already have our books published and
then
the upcoming countries as well if you
want a complete list of
where our books are available and that
list is ever expanding so a year from
now
there'll probably be even more countries
on that list we have a new book coming
out next year called love people
use things stay tuned for that also on
our website
if you're not subscribed to our email
list then you probably don't know about
this but
we just put up a new essay about
compassion it's called compassion
for hypocrites and we're going to dive
deep into this because we're going to do
an election day
episode in the near future and uh we're
gonna have some
friends from different parts of the
political spectrum
but instead of arguing with each other
debating each other
we're gonna have a discussion on how we
can have compassion for each other
and this essay is really about that you
can find it at theminimalists.com
compassion or if you're on our email
list that will show up in your
inbox or it should have showed up in
your email inbox already i'll just read
a quick snippet from this
and then you can check out the rest the
man who protests capitalism
using a megaphone he purchased from
walmart the woman who tweets about
income inequality
on a device made by underpaid workers
the environmentalist who flies to their
next save the planet rally
the political pundit who pontificates
about censorship on a media platform
that reaches millions the vegan who
sprays insecticide on her garden
the minimalist who owns six jackets
jordan you need any jackets
too bad they're mine
we're all hypocrites and we're all
suffering on some level so instead of
pointing fingers let's find compassion
for the people who disagree with us the
people who anger us the people
on the wrong side of the issue wrong is
in quotes there because of course if
someone else is on the other side of the
issue then
they must be wrong and i must be right
compassion is composed of the latin
preposition
com which means with and the verb
pass us or passion right past us which
means to suffer
meaning to have compassion we must
simply be with someone who's suffering
we needn't feel their suffering that's
empathy nor must we remove their grief
or provide countless solutions
that's something i always struggle with
guys it's someone comes with a problem i
want to fix that problem call me up
because i'm the problem solver
but sometimes the best thing to do is to
have compassion you don't need to
provide countless solutions you needn't
remove their grief it's not all it's
often not possible right
we need only bear witness and that's
what that essay is really about i can
give you a hug even if i don't agree
with you i can listen to you even if i
don't want to hear you
i can love you even if i don't like
every piece of you
if you want to read the rest of that
essay it's theminimalists.com
compassion you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcasts at the minimalist
dot com you can comment on this episode
at youtube.com
the minimalist let me know about some of
your favorite books over there
i'd love to hear and get some reading
recommendations
not so i can buy your books and store
them on a shelf
but so i can find something that adds
value to my life
and also something will add value to
other people's lives who are in those
comments as well
youtube.com the minimalist if you want
our show notes in your inbox sign up for
our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple
sunday emails whenever we send those and
if you leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all
every little thing you think that you
need
little thing you think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it